one human year equals seven dog years
myth myth we could cut it right there
certain dog breeds are hypoallergenic
because of their fur this is a major
major math only male dogs hump hi I'm
dr. Anne hoenn house I'm a staff
veterinarian at the Animal Medical
Center here in New York City my name is
dr. Carly Fox and I'm an emergency and
critical care staff veterinarian at the
Animal Medical Center today we're
debunking dogmas I think honestly the
majority of male dogs do you like to hum
but I guess me male dogs also can be
seem to exhibit that behavior but males
hump more than females
definitely yeah but I mean I guess me
male dogs can also hop I mean if they're
in the move next myth dogs are
colorblind dogs are partially colorblind
people used to think they were totally
colorblind dogs have a little bit of
ability to see color and so they see
things and kind of blue yellow and gray
but they don't see a lot of color dogs
don't like to be hacked I mean big as
mad physical touch is one of the things
that makes a dog a dog so I can't
imagine that dogs don't like to be
hugged I mean dogs will literally climb
onto your laps in order to be hugged so
this is an absolute myth you can't and
shut in just go up to any dog and hug it
dogs still are different just like
people are some people are huggers some
people are not so some dogs don't love
that very direct attention from someone
perhaps they don't know so be sure to
ask the owner if you can pad or hug
their dog and read the dog's signs next
myth one human ear equals seven dog
years
myth myth we could cut it right there
but there's some really interesting
research behind this question so the
seven years probably comes when people
live to be about 70 and dogs live to be
about 10 so 70 divided by ten is seven
that's where that number maybe comes
from nobody knows it's a myth so there's
no data behind it then a number of years
ago a group of researchers at Purdue
University looked at developing a
formula for dog age based on the size of
the dog and the dogs chronologic eight
or how many calendar years it was old
and that formula my
actually be the best this is a myth but
there are ways that you can calculate
your dog's age based on a complicated
mathematical formula next one okay you
should shave fluffy dogs in the summer
this is mostly a myth a lot of people
will shave their dogs in the summer
because they think it will make them
cooler that's not necessarily true
dogs have adapted to all types of
weather and they actually will shed
different coats at different times of
the year in order to sort of be
comfortable in that weather I think they
don't like to be shaved because they
feel naked
they have no idea yeah never not had
hair before so I'm not sure that shaving
them is always a good thing either so
myth dog's saliva can heal wounds when's
the last time you got bitten by a dog
and it's ugly
it is not healing wounds it's making
wounds worse this is a total total myth
dog bites are really nothing to laugh
about
and most veterinarians get bit on the
hand and so we're always worried because
we work with our hands so any dog bite
needs to see a veterinarian because it's
a potentially infected injury and you
need to go to your physician to have
that bite looked at certain dog breeds
are hypoallergenic because of their fur
this is a major major myth so all dogs
produce allergens and some dogs will
produce more allergens than others dogs
that don't shed like poodles or dog
smaller dogs that shed less are less
likely to produce a large amount of
allergen that can cause allergies in the
environment and it really has to do with
how often they shed or if they shed it
all but definitely all dogs produce
allergens and all dogs could be
allergenic but some dogs will produce
less and now we have a different myth
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
I think that's an idiom rather than a
myth isn't it some famous saying I think
that that is a myth the training a dog
is never easy and it involves repetition
and persistence and rewards in order to
successfully train a dog but I don't
think age is the problem I think we're
more of the problem in not sticking with
training a dog
yes they actually did a study about this
and they did the same teaching of a trip
to young dogs and old dogs dogs that
were six months to a year and then dogs
that were ten years old and they
actually found out that both sets of
dogs can learn a new trick
however the dogs that were older they
took them twice as long to learn it so
they can learn it it's just something
that requires more time and that's
definitely something that you are going
to have to commit to but it's possible
and they definitely can learn new tricks
dogs feel guilt I think that humans want
the dog to feel guilt for making a mess
chewing the furniture taking the fringe
off the sofa destroying the pillows
because we want them to be like us so I
don't think dogs necessarily can really
feel guilt but since they're not talking
it's really hard to know if that's true
or not our dogs will display guilt like
behavior when they do something wrong
like they'll put their ears back they'll
hide they'll look very guilty but I
think in most cases that's really a
reaction to you and your tone of voice
or your anger at them and your body
language rather than true guilt one of
the reasons if dogs have been so
effective in integrating themselves into
our lives the lives of humans for
millennia is because they are very good
at picking up on social cues when dogs
wag their tails it means they're happy I
would say in a lot of times when dogs
wag their tails it seems like they are
very happy
however tail wagging is a behavior in
dogs that can mean many different things
not necessarily happiness and I think
the wag matters so you've got a dog
whose tail is quivering like this that
is not a happy rag I think about the
Labrador swish swish swish swish they're
pretty much always happy and then
there's the dog who their tail Quivers
and then it curls under that's not a
happy way either that's a I'm really
upset reg so in addition to looking at
the ears and the eyes and the body
posture ask yourself what kind of wag is
this dog doing because that's gonna give
you an indication on the mood of the
beast human food is bad for dogs well
there are very particular types of
that are definitively bad for dogs for
example chocolate is obviously bad for
dogs grapes raisins are toxic to dogs
onions garlic those things are bad for
dogs however human food in general is
not necessarily bad for dogs we do want
to always limit the quantity of human
food and for dogs I usually tell people
less than 10 percent of their diet
should be human food just human food in
moderation is is not different Auguste
well dog food it's a good balanced meal
for a dog I interpreted to mean should I
cook for my dog and that is a bad idea
because what we eat is not a balanced
diet for a dog and so home cooked diets
run a huge risk of being deficient in
nutrients that are critical for your dog
mostly deficient in calcium phosphorus
so cooking for your dog unless you've
had a diet made by a board certified
veterinary nutritionist is a bad idea
dog mouths are cleaner than human mouths
no human bites are supposedly worse
although we don't see a lot of human
bites at the Animal Medical Center but
all of us have been bitten by a dog and
and we know that those can get really
badly infected what I've read is that if
a human bites another human it's awful
it's a terrible infection that you get
so no I don't I don't know that either
is better dog mouths and human mouths
are actually it's interesting they're
sort of similar both humans and dogs
have over 200 types of bacteria in their
mouth
however because disease is not really
transmissible between dogs and humans or
there's not that much is do anodic
potential between dog saliva and human
saliva they're clean and that you know
making out with your dog you won't
contract the common cold but making out
the person perhaps you can so in that
case there's they sort of are cleaner
however they still have tons and tons of
bacteria just like people mouths do dogs
are afraid of their reflection this is
just know just Google puppies in mirrors
and you'll see the dogs love that
they're so enamored of that other dog
that they'd never met before they're
really cute
dogs can't digest greens
so this is a major major mess dogs can
absolutely digest grains and not only
can they digest grains but recent
research shows that they need grain in
their diet dogs on a grain free diet are
predisposed to developing a very serious
type of heart disease called ECM or
dilated cardiomyopathy and dogs that are
on a green inclusive diet are not as
likely to develop this heart disease so
if your dog is on a green free diet it
absolutely needs green back in its diet
and you should speak to your
veterinarian about doing so putting a
dog's nose and their mess will break a
bad habit this is definitely a myth I
think this is like a training method
that people introduced a long time ago
however I think with a lot of research
and time we found out that negative
reinforcement is very bad for dogs
definitely doesn't correct bad behavior
and can actually breathe bad behavior as
well as reading aggressive behavior and
fear in our pets and that's definitely
not something that we want to do ideally
you should always reward your dog with
positive behavior like treats or
playtime or feeding rather than
punishing which is never recommended and
dogs so we talked about dogmas today and
it turns out there are a lot of myths in
fact dr. Fox and I didn't agree with
hardly any of the cues that we were
given today because most of them are
myths so beware of dr. Google be aware
of what your friends tell you or the
nice passerby on the street who tells
you you're not taking care of your dog
the right way and get an expert opinion
when it comes to your dog I'll be like
David Letterman yeah ready